well michael can i can i ask you a
question on uh regarding your book and
regarding the the sentiment that you
basically said
the
the left and the right are so far apart
politically right now on the left the
aocs the socialists that you know on the
right you want to call the marjorie
taylor green but you say america's you
don't even recognize it anymore my
question is
the people though i don't feel like the
people have moved super far left or
super far right i still think the
majority of people in america
have the same values want the same
things for their family want to have
success want to have a good life i don't
think the people have moved a certain
far left or far right direction what
have you run into as far as just regular
people go well i think we're seeing that
right now exactly what we were saying
you know unfortunately it's the
progressives that we hear from all the
time
but now that the country is going
through this economic strain
everybody i mean democrats republicans
they're all united in the same needs
listen you know i am a firm believer
that you know when it comes to uh voting
people vote first with their pockets
right they want to make sure they got
food on the table the rent is paid and
they're comfortable that way that's
number one you know and secondly
obviously safety people want to be safe
and that's shared by all americans
democrat republican doesn't matter we
only hear from the progressives and for
some reason
maybe because they got the loudest voice
i don't know what it is but
we have a tendency in this country to
really play toward the mind minorities
i don't know why it happens i don't i
don't know why we don't just shut them
down when they get so
extreme but for some reason we don't i
don't get it well pat uses an amazing
analogy you talk about there's certain
people you don't want to wake up
right
i mean would you would you break that
down you said there's a lot of people
just kind of going through the motions
working hustling doing their thing leave
me alone i don't want to be bothered but
at some point when you start pushing
somebody too much pushing they say you
know what f this i'm sick of this
exactly and a lot of americans have kind
of woken up and said
i can't deal with this crap i mean even
think about where you're at you know in
l.a rick caruso right you here's a mayor
that's kind of like hey you know here's
what we're going to be doing people are
kind of listening to this guy he's
messaging saying we kind of like this
guy running at a democrat as a democrat
he's got a lot of conservative you know
fiscal policies how do you feel about
what he's doing right now in la
you know i don't trust any of them
that's that's my problem look i always
i'll give you another example the guy in
new york what was what's his name eric
adams yeah eric adams i said okay you
know he seems like you know he's a he's
a law and order type of guy he's going
to straighten things out former police
department yeah former police captain
i'm not seeing that
he ran on that platform and now he's in
and you know the guy's more more he
wants to dress up fancy and go to all of
these you know galas that he's going to
but i don't see anything happening in
new york so i reserve decision until i
really see what's going on with them
but um i i don't know patrick i'm i'm
just so leery of all of them at this
point in time
you do have to take a risk with somebody
though right meaning like you do have to
kind of say well you know like even uh
uh kai can you pull out what elon musk
said about caruso where you know he had
some nice words to say about caruso uh
so caruso's running for mayor of l.a and
you know people are making a lot of
noise about who he is and what he's
doing just type guy kai what are you
doing just go on google and ladies and
gentlemen kai's back in the building
doing what he usually do yeah i mean
so there you go that was so easy so they
just did that so but but there's a lot
of guys that are sitting there saying
this guy may actually get some of his
policies to pass you know he may
actually
uh get some people that may favor him
and say hey we we do want to get right
there where it says the past friday elon
musk endorses caruso can you see that
right there click on that yeah can you
click on that kind there you go okay so
if we go up and see what he says there's
a tweet right there make that a little
bit bigger
los angeles is fortunate to have someone
like rick caruso running for mayor he's
awesome says elon musk wow kai can you
go back to the beginning the initial
article with the headline
if you could scroll up yeah
ex-republican back.you know so is this
what it takes to to win in a place like
la you're a former republican who has to
now
transition to a democrat right and
actually maybe you know
policy-wise you're more of a republican
but
personality-wise you got to pretend
you're a democrat that's how you kind of
got to win in l.a or in california i
mean it's so tough to win as a
republican right i don't care you know
you could you could be a republican with
democrat values and still call yourself
a republican and it would be tough
so maybe he's got the right formula i
don't know but i mean i like him so far
but
you know listen a great sign for me in
california was the fact that they threw
the attorney general out of uh san
francisco
threw him out you know in the recall and
hopefully the next one will be what's
his name from l.a because he's another
garcetti oh no not negotiation that's
the mayor attorney general's name
what's his name
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]